[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today what's
going on hey uh so I have a question uh
I'm 20 years old and I do travel
construction work and my company has a
401k type plan not exactly a
401k um I'm not sure what they called it
but they decided to cancel it and
actually handed me everything that I
contributed this morning and I was
wondering uh what I should do with St
money I'm on step two I recently just
started the plan a friend recommended it
to me um I I I got the $1,000 last week
and now I'm uh I'm yeah so I'm looking
to see what to do with that money
awesome how much is
it uh so it's a it was a 20 every $20
you put in they only put in 10 so uh
until I got my debts paid I was only
putting in about 40 bucks a week so it's
uh only $800 okay and what's your debt
on did they keep their match did they
just keep their their money so it was a
it's like this deal where until 15 years
you're not 100% invested and I was
only 15
years yeah and you're still with this
company yeah you work for the
mob uh well I'm only about a year in
with this company I'm I'm 20 years old
yeah dude you're young enough that you
don't realize that they are taking so
much advantage of you you're working for
unethical people I've never heard of it
taking 15 years to
vest yeah the percentage it goes up
every every year or something like that
but so they held your money they held
your money for a year they made interest
on your money they matched your money
and then they're like eh we're not doing
this anymore here's your money back
we'll keep the interest we earned off
your 800 bucks and we're going to keep
the money that we're going to match 15
years from
now yeah I guess so yeah it's called
sketchy so I was wondering what to do
with that and um I'm going to get into a
rth when I get my debts paid off um but
so yeah I was just wondering what to do
with that money should I save it throw
the debt you're in baby step two you
already have the, so any money above
that let's start thrown at the debt so
what's your next smallest
debt okay so yeah I have a I have a car
loan and then I have two I have a ATV
loan and I have personal loan for a
truck that I owned prev I fixed so I
could sell it because it was giving me a
lot of problems and it was just costing
me money to own you have an addiction to
wheels and Motors don't you my
man well yeah your atud I was under the
impression that it was going to build up
my credit so I purchased that when I was
18 and I found out that that was not the
case so what
dude ohy your ATV is sold this weekend
okay it's G Logan I'm so glad you're 20
because you have so much time to never
make dumb mistakes again and that gives
me great joy that you're only like two
years into adulthood and you can undo a
lot of this and still have the next 40
years to build wealth and not remain
broke yes sir so what is the next
smallest debt on the list so it's I have
a $1,700 debt um from a truck repair
that one's the first and then the ATV is
second and I owe about seven on it
what's it worth what could you sell it
for I think gets probably only worth
about four so I was planning on trying
to pay it get the difference and then
try to sell it as fast as I can okay and
the personal
loan uh well the personal loan was for
the truck fix that's the smallest one at
$1,700 and then the car Lo and then I
have a car loan at 177,000 what's this
car
worth um probably about 12 to 13
goodness and what do you
make uh I make about $50,000 a year
okay oh so we're underwater and pretty
much everything in our life and I want
to get you above water and that means
sacrifices no more toys it means working
double can you work overtime can you
pick up three more
jobs uh well I work out of town so
that's that's not actually possible for
me can you go get a different job doing
the same thing
locally um I'm not sure I I get pretty
decent hours working out of town and um
a a family member is is in this business
and he's very high up and he's kind of
guiding me to get to where he is um so
that's kind of the main reason I'm
working for the company Logan your
company
sucks I don't like this point and if I
was doing a Consulting gig and I was
sitting with your president of your
company behind Clos doors I would tell
him the same thing he's taking advantage
of 20 year
olds yes sir could you make $25 an hour
locally doing
construction uh I'm not sure it's not
really something I've looked into I make
about 22 right now I just got a so
listen homie this morning I just
mentioned this on another call this
morning I was taking my daughter to
breakfast and I drove past a sign at a
McDonald's that was starting at $20 an
hour and this is in rural
Tennessee and if you worked at
McDonald's in rural Tennessee you'd make
almost the same money except you'd get
to sleep in your own bed and you
wouldn't have to travel and you could
have friends in community and possibly
work a small weekend job job to make a
little bit more money and probably have
better benefits than what you have now I
promise you would have better
benefits you have this picture dude I'm
just I'm just telling you if you were my
brother or my son or a close friend of
mine I would tell you I don't work for
people I don't trust period I just don't
man Life's too short and if they're
going to do this to you they're going to
take advantage of you and then Pat you
on the back and then say look how great
we are dude I'm I am out I'm out man man
I'm going to start doing some homework
Logan to see what jobs are available in
my area talk to people who are doing
those jobs how much do they make do they
enjoy it and I'm going to try to work
locally so that you can bust your butt
work overtime and not be on the road and
stuck in this cycle man get a girlfriend
hang out enjoy your life smile chips and
and salsa dude